greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by on it audit comment listen you're
making resolutions you starting a new
year why [ __ ] around start without it
get the Alpha brain number one product
that they ever even [ __ ] thought of
you understand me yeah the beef jerky is
good the turkey jerky and the [ __ ]
Mexican chocolate milkshake is delicious
but hey you're trying to get your head
right you're trying to get focused
you're trying to write your goal do your
twenty two push-ups or the [ __ ] let's
start water on it go to Hana calm right
now press in church and let me tell you
what happens you get ten percent off
your first oil to deliver right to your
door like Captain Kirk you understand me
and you go alpha brain with E you don't
like it it don't work for you you're not
being focused you don't think you're
getting more energy [ __ ] call us tell
us we'll send you your money back we
don't even want the product we don't
care what you do with it I'm saying
that's the people I want to do business
with they [ __ ] stand behind their
product hundred fifty percent so go two
hundred calm and press in church bam and
get ten percent delivered right to your
crib number two are you thinking of
starting a new business you want to make
it stand out so get started with
Squarespace you think it you dream it
and you make it with Squarespace destiny
is calling it says you need a new
website come on how are you gonna have
the same website for make it with
Squarespace why because the future is
coming and you're trying to make your
business brighter and this is how you do
it so keep dreaming but making a reality
with the website from Squarespace a
dream it's just a good idea that doesn't
have the website yet making a reality
with Squarespace what I'm gonna do for
you right now is I'm gonna tell you
right now either check out
squarespace.com I know I watch it to
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial when you're ready to launch use
the offer code Church CH you are CH to
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain listen right now
you're trying to get your life together
and all this [ __ ] and listen I know it
cost
money I'm gonna give you a free trial to
put the pieces together you understand
me I need for you to get this together
but it all starts with a web page you
want to know you want to be known this
is how it starts with a web page whether
you're drawing pictures whether you're
selling socks I don't care what you do
the website starts with Squarespace head
to squarespace.com right now for a free
trial when you're ready to launch use
the promo code Church and save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain all right take that meal late
that's all you got to do oh [ __ ] yeah
Monday morning you're sitting there
thinking what the [ __ ] there's my next
step listen everybody had a hard week
last week that go on a week that we
gonna work after two weeks of confusion
Thursday and Christmas it's a
[ __ ] if you had a rough week
last week guess what I had a hell of a
[ __ ] week last week my Friday I was
just burnt the [ __ ] out
I was just burnt out mentally
emotionally psychologically I went to
[ __ ] acupuncture and thank God for
Chinese people before Jesus walked the
earth he put me back he put two thousand
needles in me I went home I drank water
I woke up Sun sadly more he had take a
piss I thought I had to wear a gas mask
in there it's more like [ __ ] Korea
from you know when they make the bombs
you shoot in Korea I thought isn't it
doctor that [ __ ] took all the
toxins out of my body anima Luke and I
had a great day sadly have a great day
today and I am and Monday is a beautiful
day to be alive
the Agostino what's going on but
something yeah how you doing the
Agostino the [ __ ] host of the home
school podcast why cuz he was
home-schooled this year now he's got
problems and they wonder why you got
this [ __ ] Mook the Lord over here how
are you my friend
I'm done beautiful Jim you're looking
good man the Agostino reason I have you
here is because I'm proud thank you you
know people I don't know what it is the
last three or four years I just had a
long conversation with a woman yesterday
who approached me as a marketing chick
and turned out to be a chick living in
her car that needed money on Christmas
Day
and she said that she wants to be an
actress
and I told her it's a long way to the
top yeah on a rock and roll and really
just uh I could tell the crowd she was
hanging around with by listening to her
hmm she said to me that a guy like me
could give her a referral into an agency
and that the agency would pay for your
headshots and all that stuff and then
they would put you on the fast track
hoggle had this girl first I thought she
was high on something yeah
and I took you here beaten something
like that and then she became my
facebook friend and yesterday like I had
a run a long Facebook message like like
she inferred to me that I talked to
friends doing projects and stuff like
that I go number one it's a great place
the great thing about living in this
town it's it's a journey and number two
is I can't take your acting classes for
you I can't make those situations for
you when you're uncomfortable when you
learn how to audition you know I
wouldn't send somebody off the street to
audition unless they fit the part
sometimes it's better just to get a
regular Joe for three or four lines to
give that scene authenticity but in my
world here in Sag there's a lot of
actors that the trying to work I can't
see that happening anymore you know I
know people with tremendous resumes then
are [ __ ] working now there's more TV
than ever
you know everybody's make an original
[ __ ] entertainment but nobody's
working but that's not the situation
here I saw you first of all I'm watching
Lee's progress okay at the same time the
last couple years I I've been watching
you you know three or four I mentioned
nine years ago
yeah we're young kid actor haha and you
would put me up at night with no drama
and nobody would bother me tell me when
to go there ten minutes later I was up
I'd walk out there was no podcast nobody
knew about a podcast
right I was just working on Gabriel a
she's thing and the whole [ __ ] deal
and that after a few years are you
working at the haha which is a comedy
club in North Hollywood that's been
there since Jesus but Chicago yeah they
recently moved to a new location that's
very nice and stuff and it's a great
club whatever it fits if it's a
different need then the county storm or
a factory improv it has its complete
different flavor just how flappers has a
complete different need when you walk
into flappers they don't have [ __ ]
Whitney Cummings down on a Tuesday night
and and Sebastian and [ __ ] eighteen
other killers you know they have Whitney
Cummings doing a guest of the new stuff
and that's it and Thomas you've never
seen or heard from before I'm not
playing them down in any way but I saw
you you know work at the [ __ ] thing
and then you worked until you looked at
the Arabian check you a marry the right
right right yeah with the CBD OCD touch
glass you couldn't be in the house you
can take your shoes off you had to sit
there she'd spray Lysol on every angel
[ __ ] where it is the time go man praise
that was crazy we went over there for
Christmas to one year yeah go Italy
there's not past no Lee get on a [ __ ]
plane I'm with the girl I'm gonna drunk
oh that's right that's where what I made
lasagna yeah yeah I'm gonna marry I'm my
wait gonna playing before I shoot you a
girl just before we throw numbers in
that thought she would be the tenth
that's exactly what you said to me there
I wasn't you gotta be yelling and
screaming Jesus because he goes I'm here
in Boston showing the girl I'm gonna
marry that nice home platelets I don't
give a [ __ ] what you're showing her all
you need to show is your dick and play
Spanish music I came back to Mexico
that's all you need to do get home and
do the podcast that was your living with
her yeah then you got a divorce yeah and
then you hook the puts in the [ __ ]
chicken I'm like what is he doing
this guy [ __ ] he just got out and
then you quit the haha yeah which were
people who don't know about this this is
the biggest transition in your life
it really is it's getting to a point in
your life when you have to tell somebody
you have to move on yeah some people
leave a note to never call you some
people but there's a day that you look
at a job and you know you know what man
I've done my time I've been a loyal
servant I'm gonna move on because I've
seen every comic come through here I've
asked every question right yes every
question yeah you know I worked for the
comedy club and it was my life you
definitely learn a lot like my job I
hadn't either at five I was there to
call it a five waiting for the comic to
come in so I could ask him if he needed
water and then I would ask him questions
how was the road oh it sucks man mm-hm I
got four kids I gotta pay child support
huh I'm also a school teacher so I gotta
get back on the car and drive to Mexico
tonight damn and teach at school late in
the morning you know you talk to all
these different types of comics you get
to see it from the perspective that a
lot of people don't see it you're
working in at a club I mean on TV you
see a guy for 20 minutes he seems like a
sweet guy he's funny
meanwhile I'm between shows he's [ __ ]
mine is up to a street heroine in the
green room but if you open up the door
he'll get you fired man says he's one of
those [ __ ] guys if we've seen it
lately huh yeah yeah you know just a
bunch of just mischief there's some
green rooms and [ __ ] so you quit this
job and it's funny I tell people this
all the time and I did it I did it for a
long time that transition for me was
1994-95 I was just starting to cover my
nut work ami what's coming my nut 800 a
month
I was pulling down 800 a month three
four months in a row I would steal a low
more and bring it back a summit Kmart I
always find ways to to help supplement
my income my family income but in
Boulder from like December of 94 to May
of 94 I was between 800 and 900 a month
just through the forties fifties and
hundred our bills maybe at 201 he'd I'm
saying yeah that's how I made a living
but at the same time I was still getting
up and selling cars at a used-car dealer
and he's Koufax
trying to squeeze up $3,000 and I was
there physically but I wasn't there
mentally like mentally I could not wait
to get on the road yeah like I was ready
I was killing in all these rooms I was
doing 20 minutes I could leave to be
like the rest of these guys and sit this
[ __ ] cert comedy [ __ ] circuit or I
could do something about it I had a
little [ __ ] car then had everything
you needed in there you know and I'll
never forget going to them no I didn't
have to tell the boss I quit the car
they gave me as a demo blew up one day
and I just left the damn [ __ ] and he
called me you [ __ ] you [ __ ] I just
never went back and damn and I became a
professional comedian was that in
Colorado this is in Colorado and I'll
never forget how scared I was
and don't get me wrong I always did
something everywhere like all the triple
ones I would bring my pencil Kmart you
know this is nothing to be embarrassed
about this out broke you get now you
start doing it now fact when I got the
Seattle if I could sell coke I would
sell Nate Wallach oh I didn't give a
[ __ ] that was taking bets I was doing
whatever I had to discipline my comic
income because in the beginning of the
month you all started zero that's a very
scary thought
I work on commission I'm not different
than any of you two guys at the
beginning of the month I started zero
everything I bring in after that is
cherries grapes then sometimes you bring
home wood grain well every month I
started zero well we're not showing up
to a job every day we're not punching in
you punch it anywhere you are you do but
I get the reference' it's just really
weird that but in that time I've watched
you grown as a comic like you even with
this day job which I know you need to
sustain yeah married or whatever
eventually one day you gonna have to
give up this day job sure so I'm talking
to the other day and I had heard it from
shubra I had heard it from a couple
people somebody mentioned to me at the
store did you kill them one of the rules
one night the Mellie ruin the Sun right
there okay and then Schubert said that
you were getting really good yeah I had
a great week with him and I sat down I
thought to myself well two years you
know when you keep when you tell
somebody like my talk like them when
people come in here and they sit across
from me and leaves him he's been doing
comedy for a year and Lee gets little
breaks in the time to time at the store
the main room here of that I won't leave
I understand that anybody else I give
you an electrician and you you start as
an apprentice the first year is murder
yeah the first year is the hardest
[ __ ] in the year of your life or and
in reality it's the easiest year of your
life yeah because after that it gets
really [ __ ] hard and no matter what
level you're at there's always gonna be
resistance at that level whether you
work in the electrician is you you know
let's say the electricians unit right
you have to you're uh let's say you
start as a residential wire that means
you're a you're an electrician how
but well basically that means that the
electrician comes in and says to you
today D'Agostino I need this room Wyatt
straining it outlet another outlet for
lights and he gotta hook up some type of
panel and he leaves and basically he
charges $48,000 for that worked but he
pays you 850 yep yeah and he even though
you getting [ __ ] in the ass this is
what it takes to be an apprentice you
gotta pay your dues mm-hmm and then you
get good at it you know you're good at
it then one day that you need an off
send you on a commercial job and you
have to start bending pipe and making
saddles and do you ever go into a room
and you look at an outlet and it's got
pipe going in and I think that pipe was
bent later that pie came like that bent
no you gotta get a pencil and do math
and measure and bend the pipe just
perfectly and [ __ ] install it it's a
lot of work when you do a bathroom you
got a huge EGF I outlets so if the
electricity is plugged into your raise
when it falls in the water the shark
stops in the room that was that said I
was the law in the end the bathroom I
never happen so but when you're an
electrician after three look like after
90 days I was born in the houses and I'm
a [ __ ] any guy but I took the course
from the the electrician's the guy who
did the inspections for the town so he
taught me everything how to do in code
so it was a three month course and the
project was at the end you had a wire
house but that was the final job so he
would put a graduation yes he would put
me and you in a [ __ ] a house that was
under construction and he would make
this wire room and I did such a good job
don't wanna hide that night on the walk
back he goes hey you want to get you
jobs on attrition to help a tomorrow
just let me know I go yeah make the corn
he got me a job so they started figuring
out that all the jobs I did by myself
the guy would pass because I was he was
nice
I was the student mm-hmm so that well
they would always though the rumor was
whatever that guy comes to doing the
special just leave Joey with oh don't
even be here because he would walk me
through the inspection and look at
things and go why'd you order that out
of hat yeah yeah it was tremendous but
my point is that I had a bet and even
though I knew they were charging forty
to fifty an hour I was getting nine
dollars you know and then I'm making
money off me my point being that working
is hard but in every position you have
to serve an apprenticeship and I've seen
you do it yeah you know I've seen young
Dean downright do it you've been doing
calming longer than Dean yeah that's
crazy I was uh I brought up Dean the
first time on stage at an open mic yeah
and there's no time limit to getting
exposure anymore it used to be a lot
longer than what it was that was them
years ago you had to come here Tulane
get into one of the clubs and [ __ ]
wait for HBO was Comedy Central one of
them to give you a spot and once you got
that type of exposure now you don't need
that dumb one with the internet so
people know we'll all three you
[ __ ] look like you know saying
like that they know what everybody looks
like what I wanted the stress at this
podcast and while I'm so proud of you is
that you went from the guy you quit this
job you want from hustling little gigs
you know again because of your marriage
and whatever was which I was against in
the beginning because I wanted you to
understand the concept of comedy comedy
when you go on stage you're by yourself
okay I was watching The Sopranos last
week and I was thinking about what a
horrible life that you're hanging out
with your friends right we're friends
right and we do everything together we
steal together we rob trucks together
an old man approaches us that says hey
man you weren't [ __ ] chubby over here
and the [ __ ] whole school up I've
been making three four G's robbing
trucks you're with me now
and all of a sudden we start robbing
trucks with this guy and he gives us
[ __ ] now were robbing big-time trucks
with $15,000 apiece then we're driving
nice cars this [ __ ] and all of a sudden
one day we gets a call that me and you
gotta go meet [ __ ] George Perez and
shoot him in the head and next thing you
know they're taking us to a room and
then put a needle in our finger and
we're in the [ __ ] mafia and next
thing you know that's what we do me or
later in the [ __ ] mafia and we're
shooting people and we're jamming every
night but somewhere along in that one
day you meet a girl and you get married
and when they leave meets a girl he gets
married and one day I meet a girl and I
get married and then we start having
kids well guess what you still not
allowed to shoot people yeah that's when
it gets [ __ ] weird when you still are
gonna shoot people and come home like
well you've nothing to happen and you
gotta sustain a house like 6 7 8 G's a
month plus the six you gotta kick
upstairs so to make this type of money
you're booking your son heroin but at
the end of the day you're going to a
nice house when you do comedy in the
beginning it's great to do but it's
harder to do with somebody at home do
you know I'm saying yeah
that's what I was against your marriage
I like Jen ya know yeah I just felt that
if you were gonna do calmly if you quit
the hard it was to do town it wasn't to
do anything else like go home to your
mom and go ma I'm renting out that
closet I'm giving you two hundred a
month for the closet I'll send it to
your money on see you know when I'm
gonna go on the road for a year and make
my name for myself and work these shitty
[ __ ] home
get ripped off and work for french fries
and sleep in your car then you come back
here and you now when you go to the
improv they tell you they don't want it
who gives a [ __ ] I know I paid my dues
you know I'm saying something you come
back for two or three months and you go
back out there for another nine or ten
and you live on the commando rules
see I'm saying very cheap veggie and
cheese sandwiches in subway you lose 30
40 pounds you work out at the hotels or
no hotels or you bring wait for you in
the trunk of your car I had a basketball
in the trunk of my car frisbee I had
everything never to be bored when I
first started cop you know I didn't want
Jen to go through that with you you know
right obviously you adjusted the game
for yourself
yeah yourself a little day job he just
kept nipping at the bud
Monday night you go to your boys room
used a night mmm a roast it has a room
next thing you don't spots it to calm
the storm yeah you're not a regular but
you still have to store your in the
formerly right exact not playing for the
Yankees but you're playing for their
[ __ ] farm team yeah and it's really
we how long have you been doing family
for now in February you'll be ten years
old this February February 4th yeah man
if I mean I got lucky man Jen's super
understanding about everything but I
never made the day job an excuse because
I knew that that would be easy to do is
to Co I'm tired
when you get a have a 8-hour shift you
know I always make sure that I'm out
even afterward I mean I tell you all the
time I hate sometimes I don't go home I
just go straight to whatever if I have a
spot I make sure I do two podcasts a
week I mean I realize that consistency
is the [ __ ] game to play how do you
that dirty yes yeah well you can't [ __ ]
around
you started dirty you start realizing
what makes sense and what doesn't you
don't see the whole playing field but
you at least start to make sense how's
it been for you like with the day job
and going on at nights
I mean it's [ __ ] rock I mean some
days I am tired you know it's exhausting
but I mean
young what am I gonna do you know I got
to do it now I don't want to be doing it
when I'm 50 I'm in nights a week these
go up four or five four or five and then
always to podcasts a week and you know
you I I'm starting to see people telling
me things like you're getting better
like you told me I'm getting better
Schubert everyone started tell me -
you're getting funny you're getting
strong and it's really nice to finally
see it you know when I did those shows
with him in Arizona there was a tree did
in five days and every single show at
least one person came out from my
podcast you know and it's finally great
to start to get recognition because
doing the podcast for like a year or
more is like you at one point I asked
myself like what am I doing this for you
know you start to see like the numbers
not really getting higher and then but I
just got to keep going so like that
little bit of like people tell me bro
you're getting really [ __ ] funny or
people on Twitter going like all great
podcast I started to go okay it just
keeps me going like another year you
know I tell people this is a game in 90
days when I was doing comedy it was a 90
day thing I didn't know nothing beyond
90 days nor did I wanna know yeah all I
was worried about what this week is I
got a spot next week at Arizona I got a
spot the week after that of Spokane you
know I didn't worry about that long
distant goal even though I had the goal
where I wanted to be a realm on that I
didn't think about it as much as the
next 90 [ __ ] days you know and I
still remember having a day job and
don't comment like that was rough yeah
that was rough going home taking a
shower or sometimes yeah sometimes and
sometimes going right to the gig at 8:00
and being the second time the couple and
then going on yeah you know go or
sometimes you rush all the way over
there and you bet your last and then
your [ __ ] to go home at 2:00 in the
morning and then you can follow you're
all wired up from being onstage you
gotta try to fall asleep thing if I was
sleeping I'd do the whole thing all over
again you know so when you did the thing
with Schubert yeah so Mika approach
said that if you put together something
they might be able to get you into a
festival right my biggest prestigious
festivals in the country known for
comedy I know but invited now they want
me to go I've also never been invited
well I was struggling nobody wanted to
see me yeah that's how it goes man
that's crazy how I thought about it last
night when I called you up to be on the
podcast I thought about those a I was
very proud of it and be yeah people do
things for the wrong reason sometimes
there was a guy that came on this
podcast a lot that I loved dearly told
his dad loved dearly but I lost a piece
of respect from when he told me he got
rid of his podcast because it didn't do
anything for his career that's what the
biggest list number misnomer is with
these things and it bothers the [ __ ] out
of me I don't normally nights I'm Satya
and I'd be will Diddley on why he hasn't
opened if he opened up at Cass school
call it become the next Joe Rogan yeah
it would be off the chain your phone
wouldn't stop the [ __ ] credit cards
wouldn't stop pouring it you know you
remember 10 years ago you came out here
and I've said this before because of S&L
hmm and you joined Groundlings or
improbable and fixing you did the whole
eight-year program and you got
discovered then they put you on a sketch
show for Fox with six episodes and they
can't switch it you know there's really
no it's either SNL I'll go [ __ ] your
mother you know it's just like the wings
with that should it see the head
surround go [ __ ] your mother and they
look for what 20 to 25 year old on SNL
after that you're pretty much done right
they look for young cats on that so it's
a short window I don't know what I was
going with this yeah doesn't matter it's
like it's so weird how I just watched
you keep grinding it out
you didn't ask questions Jimmy Schubert
owes you work I throw you work obviously
gonna
San Jose with wife's Valentine's Day
weekend it's just really weird and then
the end they li said to me I came in and
he knows you know what I've been doing
counted for a year I did 480 sets the
other thing I was very happy fully but
again I'm one of those guys that I don't
think this stuff I live so much in the
moment I don't think about stuff as
people were saying it to me mmm I think
about stuff later I've noticed he's a
liar he's been on stage since October of
2016
I didn't forgot like five times [ __ ]
that yeah you good like five times see
they weren't doing comedy for a year I'm
really breaking his ball I'm really
breaking his balls people I know Lisa at
four I don't know how many he is
probably eight years and he can't stick
to nothing for ten days people ten days
I live this days I want to cry
he's the 10-day three week guy and then
something happens the food didn't get
the livid remember the juicer we want
that you say oh I have to grudge match
he was he was so big you with Chinese
guy with you they kept saying Charlie's
God I'm like that's leave then he [ __ ]
showed up for the day like he had AIDS
his lips were sucked in
he's I come on the juicer I've been
living on [ __ ] carrots and ginger and
he would sit here with this green paste
and drinking in front of me just look in
his face like it was like I had the
taste of tens different sperms and
they're shaking up and he got really
[ __ ] skinny and then he snapped he
met Paula demon yeah of course he went
no there's a point there he lost a lot
of weight the other way though I lost
twice cuz then I lost weight kettlebells
that [ __ ] juice I got more dust than
[ __ ] sister Theresa was you still got
the juicer bro it's hidden yeah it's
hidden oh yeah every time I think about
doing it I think about him boy he's got
[ __ ] camouflage on the tree [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's had [ __ ] it's like that bombs
and grenades it's between the toes there
in the blender I'm saying
Lee is from that generation that a like
a lot of us we don't let the miracle
happen you have to let that you have to
put the time and don't let the miracle
happen but Joey
I don't have five years my father wants
me to join the army then next something
and commit to it and stick around till
the miracle happens you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised I don't care if you
work at Foot Locker and you're like you
know what I got a college degree in
marketing and business is the best I
could get there's a sales job is full
okay going there with the intention of
taking over the company coming there
with a simple thought you know take over
the company but what does that mean okay
that means if the first six months next
year when you get the job you're the
salesman of the month and they make you
assistant managing your store sales run
a month then they make it managing
yourselves on a month then what's the
next move district manage and how you're
telling [ __ ] people hada how the run
for stores how to use different sales
techniques and hada it all start
somewhere we don't believe in that no
more
we believe in the system that we go to
college get the diploma and we want to
go right to that position
and I wish it was like that but I see
exactly like you and for example we that
Leah's building some dives that it
bothers me what I understand he needs to
do there's nothing I can do about it I
can't do the work for you if you look at
a [ __ ] any when you're in the fourth
grade
how much do you hate that math teacher
haha because remember you would come
home but it's all in the kitchen
start a conversation with your father by
Germany is something that he was
interested in and then start hitting him
with stupid [ __ ] questions
what's 21 and 40s
he would give it to you write it down
what's right then you get the answers
from him the next day and the teacher
would say where's to show me to work
where's the welcome there's not a one
over the eight yeah you know what you
just wrote the answer yeah because I
erased it go home go do it again when
you first did times table yeah you got
to do the work in a dessert on me I get
so frustrated exactly yeah that all that
show me the work frustrates everybody
yeah why people either get in or get the
[ __ ] [ __ ] here we've seen in the last
year we've heard people angry at me that
they wanted help they made they did
podcast they did videos this not that
you can't help somebody I can point you
in the right direction to tell you the
steps yeah but I can't give you the best
gift anybody could give you that's
patience do you want me to sit here and
tell you I had patience and be a [ __ ]
hypocrite every 90 days I'm gonna cook
Benjen cry you know this guy was going
to Montreal this guy booked a movie this
guy signed Alaia CAA this guy signed
will I see him yeah and Here I am with
the coloring book talent agency you know
and and you catch yourself doing it and
you go like I shouldn't be now it's not
even jealousy but I shouldn't be like
worried about what that guy got and I
did you know yet you're doing it when
you're doing it well you shouldn't do it
once you see how much time your mind is
taking on that stupid energy yeah you
realize that that energy should be
focused a new total yourself better I
mean it's such a human reaction though
is to go like man I'm sitting here
watching people fly by oh no no and
that's the problem you don't know what
time you don't know what time all I want
you to do is know that when that time
comes
you better be covered Joey what are you
saying
one it off you can work on for an
electricians helper for four [ __ ]
years you've been late three times one
day you missed because
sister-in-law got hit by a car but
besides that you're always on time
you're always the last one to go you
know there's four different apprentices
yeah first one in last one out you're
the best apprentice they got you trusted
they give you a truck some nights you
bend pipe you install [ __ ] power on
the poles you can start from A to Z
you're ready to become an electrician or
you're doing this you need more
man-hours and you probably need to not
take up like a written test mmm because
he's after three years no nutrition as a
help you become a residential wired that
means I could leave you on your wall
along the wire house that means you
could get some dough
16 an hour or 15 an hour 1750 now it's
not a bad living guys especially of you
your Union Oh in a year and the
apprentice program because with the
Union you have to take a certain amount
of classes every week but once you take
those classes still you have to put in
the man-hours so once you have enough
hours like I might be I'm doing jujitsu
five six years now I'm terrible I'm
[ __ ] terrible but there might be a
guy that's been doing jujitsu for two
years and he's just sensational if I
focus on him I'll lose my jujitsu game
when I look at people's bounce when I
roll with them I [ __ ] him lose
mentally it's the same thing with Tommy
you know and what you did I mean I'm
really [ __ ] blown away D'Agostino I'm
really blown away and evenly I'm really
blown away especially like I said he
can't do nothing straight for two weeks
bronchitis swim by this his mother's
coming to town but you know what he
looks at it he understands it you know
I'm happy this is his first year but
good luck yeah I'll see you in eight
years then come talk to me let me know
what you think you know what's funny
I've never really been [ __ ] captain
commitment either you know like I just I
was home-schooled so
you're talking about is with with the
math and stuff I was doing it with my
mom in the kitchen that's where we did
to school and then he got ahead leave
the table and go do homework by herself
but then when you're doing the work here
to bring it back to your mom and I'm you
know I mean I imagine a lot of kids that
go to public school you were going to
school because your parents pushed you
or society pushes you no one was like
really pushing me in my household and
when you do homeschool do you like you
gotta it's up to you to do it I wouldn't
do it I just would I just [ __ ]
wouldn't do it I hated school and there
came like a point where my dad had like
a really bad surgery he lost his kidney
when I was when I was like a really
really young teenager and someone he was
in the hospital at I my mom was taking
care of him
no one was pushing me to do school and I
just [ __ ] stopped I I just wouldn't
do it I went like grades missed so then
I towards the end when people started to
pay attention me again I had to like
make up for so much back work you know
and then I didn't go to college I went
and just did like jobs right away you
know jobs at the mall whatever jobs I
can find what I've always quit to do
that job I was quickly I get sick of
stuff really quick but stand-up is the
only thing that I did with me pushing me
you know like that that was the
everything else someone had to tell me
to go do it but stand-up I like I don't
know it's 10 years like the longest I've
done anything straight I had a problem
where if I didn't like it if I didn't
enjoy it like even in school like I
liked history in English I would do well
on those classes but math and stuff like
my mom would was on me so if I didn't
get at least a B I'd get in trouble or
something so like I would work hard and
work hard enough to get a B but that was
about it
but if I enjoy it like what stand up
then for what I don't know and I I think
it's and that that's what life is
working hard at something that you don't
like but staying with that problem Dean
ups got failing too but it buddy you
like it if you like something you just
like something you like it's good I
guess bad stage quickly yeah like it
even if it's only one day bombing don't
bother gratifications a little quicker
like you just you just learned it's just
a learning experience I feel really bad
and I've said this before on the podcast
and I meet you
get that tissue paper on it you spit I
don't give a [ __ ] okay I'm a little
Jubilee Jew DNA is good for yourself I
hate when I see anybody quit anything
yeah because I quit so many things
growing up to lie I quit the base I quit
the guitar you know like I said before
I've had every job and every episode if
I wanted to do it I can do it if I would
just say oh that looks interesting I
used to be one of those [ __ ] oh that
was interesting but once they made you
do it
mm-hmm you like this socks yeah like
before the movie cocktail came up I just
like what my mom did it looked like it
was easy bartending look yeah it looks
fun it looks fun it looks fun
if you had the right bond everybody's
doing blowing each other in the end
that's what you see in Carlito's Way
right there I think there's a dancing in
show like that I've worked at those bars
yeah that's not a real reality right you
know and uh it's number one the first
time you get on look the first thought
that Stan oh I mean Stan hope that
stand-up must be for you what what woman
was it because I know one thing for sure
and this is what I know people are real
when they're a student of the game
hmm Mike Tyson is [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
hate to say that not to mention he got
hit in the head 10,000 times if I sit
Mike Tyson here and talk to him about
fights we just sit here for 10 hours and
he'll point to me to every classic fight
he knows every classic fight all the way
back to the nineteen hundreds even in
England you know because they become
students of the game explain to me how
come he came into your life was Dane
Cook one of your early influence yeah
absolutely when the mirror jumping up
and down
you know what I was a giant fan of
stand-up before I ever even thought I
would ever do it
I just my dad was really into jiu-jitsu
and all that [ __ ] like that and try to
get me into it I was really just more
into comedy watching it there was not
really specials back then but you can go
buy like a VHS tape of comics you know
and I would just that's what I would do
I'd go get CDs and then you I remember
Dane Cook was the one that kind of made
stand-up popular again like all of a
sudden my friends were telling me about
stand-up I've been telling you guys
about it for years and now you want to
tell me about who are you turning on at
first but I was listening to Bill Cosby
okay when I was a kid I feel guilty that
a little bit now like a little party you
a fan of a child rapist I don't feel
guilty I feel really bizarre about it I
get mad at Lee through this day cuz I'll
never forget that they told me really
how much you paid I think it was free
Paula I wanted I want to go see him at
Cerritos I didn't like him after 92 yeah
way before the rape charges I didn't
like him since 94 since the Colorado
well he was obviously a [ __ ] mr.
hypocrite I know that yeah I've been
through up here so it was Cosby first
I'd say Cosby yeah this is one of the
first hours I watched watched watched
was it was it the one with the dentist
look Cosby himself yeah that's that what
was it came on it was like on an HBO
special they they aired it on like HBO
or Showtime I want to learn about
stand-up at the time did your friends
say did you watch the stand-up comedian
and you when I was 11 I went to a comedy
club and we're at the ha ha ha ha and it
the stage was on the other side and I
wasn't allowed to be in there not really
but you know how that works like oh
you're here with your mom and dad it's
fine you know and I went in there and I
don't know what I was walking into I
knew of stand-up I never really saw it
before and then I walked in there and it
was like it was a black night was pretty
heavy heavy black comics what you think
if I was 11
then [ __ ] horrible math 19 1999 yeah 99
2000 yes and a lot of black comics in
there just really [ __ ] funny one guy
he's not only thing he's a stand-up
anymore
he he worked with my dad my dad was a
telemarketer at the Daily News and that
guy worked there and he invited my dad
to the show that's why I went and I went
to go watch my dad's coworker and he
[ __ ] did this when the r.kelly
hot and fresh out the kitchen song was
was hot he did like a whole parody on it
and like today if I see you doing music
now that I know about stand-up I'll
[ __ ] walk out of the room
but at the time I was like this is like
a whole new world of stand-up and I just
and then I watched the Bill Cosby thing
that my family would watch the George
Lopez we were talking about earlier the
why you crying we I watched out my fan
I would watch stand-up with my family I
always loved comedy movies I'm a [ __ ]
big sitcom guy you know I'd watch ever
to lose weight with my parents then I
found out Ray Romano did stand-up and I
was like oh [ __ ] I had his album live at
Carnegie Hill and then I remember I
started to go the only public school
type thing I did was was Catholic school
when you get you're not communion but
confirmation I started to go and then uh
one day in the confirmation we had like
a retreat where everybody had to like do
something yeah everybody had like a
retreat is all we were like 14 we all
had to do something and I didn't have
anything to do no talent like that and I
went up then I remember one Bill Cosby
joke and I went up there and told the
Bill Cosby joke and I I said it like it
was mine you know because I'm like these
kids I don't know the [ __ ] Bill
Cosby's jokes so I did that and then I
and then I started to think like maybe I
could do stand-up and when I was maybe
16 I still got the notebook I wrote I
wrote an act never performed it never
once but I wrote like ideas I wrote like
an act like about like my nieces and
nephews and jokes about my mom and stuff
like that and then I used to go for
walks is like I said I was home-schooled
I didn't have too many friends besides
the kids in my neighborhood and I walked
down to their house and while I would
walk I would listen to my Walkman and I
had one of the Dane Cook CDs at the time
when he was hot and I remember that
first track
where it goes track one where it's like
ladies and gentlemen Joey Diaz in the
crowd it's like ah you know the track
one when you always hear that but Dane
Cook's out and they kept going like give
it up for Dane Cook and I just kept hit
and repeat repeat repeat I kept getting
like like anxiety and and and like like
a high from here in the audience cheer
for you you know and I just thought like
I'd say I want to [ __ ] do it and I
kept telling myself I want to do it and
then like some family members and some
friends and siding that encouraged me
and I finally did when I was twenty I
was working some mall job and they laid
me off and I got unemployment and I was
like well I'm gonna try to do stand-up
on my unemployment and I know for I went
to the the improv of Mike because at
that time I started going to after I
turn 18 I would go to any 18 and over
show and The Improv had the early shows
were 18 and over the late shows are 21
and over so I would go to the early
shows and I started with the improv a
lot I would watch all those guys I
remember being there one night and it
was like when they were filming the
movie funny people remember with Adam
Sandler and all those guys and I went
down there one night and everybody from
that movie came down there to work on
stand-up and they're not even stand-ups
Jonah Hill one on stage Seth Rogen went
on the stage and then they and then they
put on like real comics I remember like
Ben Morrison was there and like [ __ ]
Greg Wilson and richer on a [ __ ] all
those guys I closed out the show and I
just remember thinking my stuff like man
I always like imagine that's me I'm just
gonna [ __ ] do it I picked I asked
open mic when's your open mic The Improv
ask someone's rope my they go Tuesday
nights I went down there and I signed up
I was 20 years old and I never stopped
you got on yeah now you know it's like
what rare to get on there it was R at a
raffle back then too but I didn't know
that
I thought you sign up and everybody got
up cuz I got up the first time so the
second time I went back is when I found
out that it was by chance
very very green to the situation of how
it worked and how long now what we don't
for work that you are them I've done
unemployment living at home yeah I still
living at home and what did you think
the fact you got off stage for the first
time it felt so good it felt really
really good like I thought I thought I
did better than I actually
because I was more happy that I actually
did it I was more impressed with myself
that I did had the courage to do it so
the second time I went back I thought
I'm gonna do great tight to when I ate a
bag of dicks my second time my second
time they just [ __ ] stared at me
where would you suck of that same place
in profit and then then I after that I
started going on like Craigslist to look
for shows I went on Craigslist in and
like you know all these guys that run
bringer rumors will put ads on
Craigslist like hey I'll book you at The
Comedy Store and I of course you're a
[ __ ] kid and you're like oh I'll
answer this ad but it's really just the
way to get bringer's which I didn't give
a [ __ ] I mean I brought people when
you're new you [ __ ] bring people to
get on stage and so that's why I did
this guy named uh [ __ ] forget
something gold
Joey gold from New York I booked me on
like a belly room show then I met
somebody else so booked me on this show
and then I went over to the haha mic one
day and that's how I started there how
long before you started working there um
maybe a year and a half after you
started going there really for the open
mic yeah cuz it used to be run by Eric
Alegria was one of the guys pretty much
booked in the shows there and Rico and
then I started to go with Oh Mike's in
became close with those friends and then
they would put me on their Tuesday night
show Tuesday night was like when you
know I had him Hunter would go by and
Darren Carter go by and they'd give him
ten minutes and then like they'd throw a
guy like me on for five and they started
giving me then eventually you know I got
tight with Jack just because I was
always bringing a lot of people and I
was always there every single day for
the open mikes and then [ __ ] just
happened they go you want to do your own
show and I was like sure that's how it
starts you do your own show that turns
into you [ __ ] work in there then you
can't bring people no more because all
your friends foot and saw you already
now it's like okay well we'll text these
phone numbers and invite people for free
tickets to come out and then you'll get
five minutes on the stage okay cool you
know you DJ four spots what a hole sorry
it's having a club giving away tickets I
know what I got here the Comedy Store
had a room
upstairs makes the Pauli's office and it
was five phones the guy that ran this
was Ed's Mitchell who was now the owner
of that club on Pico the black club on
Pico
oh really the Union the union of the
Union and this Mitchell was a good guy
affair and it was me shame attached and
the guy that was dating Kelly Kirsten I
just see how I'm lying I forget what his
name was maybe to all of us and our job
was just to call businesses every day hi
my name is joi Diaz I'm gonna Tommy
store I love you heard legendary comedy
store on the Sunset Strip is where pride
kind of I start to Korean babies won't
call you before you hang up is we do a
promotional night once a month and we
picked your businesses one of the
businesses yeah we have 110 tickets yeah
we wanted off April 23rd of work V oh my
god I won ten tickets to The Comedy
Store where someone to the comedy store
the Murphy was there you got yeah yeah
and then we would and then the next
month but they get a call again they go
wait a minute oh yeah I keep winning you
would call him and I got so good at I
just became friends of most of these
people yeah yeah so he would call me
when they wanted tickets right yeah
that's how yeah all the time
you've always want a free ticket of the
Sunset Strip I mean for Christ's sakes
insanity bucks that's parking you know
right parking but there was two scams
going on at the store there was the
phone scam and they just paid you a flat
rate but there was also the card scam
which was two-for-one tickets and if you
were accounting and you put your name
behind it you got a dollar for each
ticket at the end of the week so at this
time of the year both yeah like from the
26th on I would drive my car to universe
so pay like seven bucks in those days
the park and I would get in the middle
of Universal by the fountain yes and
that would just give away tourists take
with your signature that would get there
at night there'd be 60 people
Wow yeah it was crazy because they [ __ ]
who doesn't want to go it's a pretty
good turnout
yeah who doesn't wanna listen this I did
it off like when I worked in New York I
worked for a place the comic strip you
want in there
oh you want to be an open mic I'm fine
grab a pen and they give you tickets
they give you physical techniques and
you'd have to sell them by the block so
was ten blocks eight eight tickets in
each block there was eight hours and you
kept 40 of it it was the creepiest thing
yeah so the first couple days I latched
on with the other comics that would
stand on line for the open mic and I
would [ __ ] sell those things
door-to-door Manhattan I just go into
businesses and it worked for about two
weeks
don't one that I got coked up and I
spent they ate it up and they were back
I was embarrassed but it's just amazing
the things they make you do at the
beginning for you to be on your comic
and you're not selling you so it's
something that it's also paying dues
listen it's paying you do is there even
whatever you know way before that I
worked at wit's end it was a club in
Westminster Colorado when I first
started at first I started as security
as a doorman and then I started a
security cedar and then they made me a
DJ and I used to be the security the
cedar and the [ __ ] DJ and they think
I think they gave me like a dollar race
and that's what you know I mean I was
never home I was there from Tuesday to
Sunday yeah and I had a roofing job in
the daytime from [ __ ] 6:00 to 3:00 in
the afternoon so I was putting in the
hours jack yeah but I asked all the
questions I had them
it took me from Mike February it took me
to July to get on stage and once I got
on stage there pretty much fired me they
didn't want me that
mmm because they were like you wanna do
stand-up we can't have you know cuz I
asked let me do guess that ya know this
is what we were scared of we don't want
the DJ to do stand-up Micheline won't
take a [ __ ] hike yeah what do you
think I was in it for for the money
yeah because you guys paced so great
books about those tips at yeah but you
know there was like when I first made
that transition of like knowing it's
time to get the [ __ ] out of working at
the club when I first did that I had a
really bad grudge towards the club and I
mean we both did our things to each
other but I'm like right now III have
I'm out of like a really peaceful place
where I just go like you know what man
like I had to learn that [ __ ] eventually
I really did learn a lot about the
business working there and I used to
tell myself if I didn't work here for
the first five years of my career I
would have been five years more ahead I
would have been at the Comedy Store five
years ago you know what I haven't worked
in five years I'm still not a regularly
Comedy Store but I learned a lot and I
would have had to learn it eventually
same thing with my first marriage when I
first broke up with her I was like
[ __ ] up at you know name you know I
was I had so much anger towards you
explain whatever you spit on Russian
yeah but you know like I I look back
towards my ex-wife now and I don't have
any hatred towards her like I did a
[ __ ] I was I wasn't great either I was
too young to be a husband and [ __ ]
not home working on a shitty salary also
out [ __ ] Monday through Saturday
working at the comedy club wasn't there
what woman was gonna be happy yeah yeah
there's no woman with some women about
security you know and the daytime
security has to be covered
a woman Security's coverage you don't
give a [ __ ] if you [ __ ] hang yourself
surely you can show you how to do a boy
and a nut so keeps you the boardgame
that that's another than the Boy Scouts
that'll get you God she don't give a
[ __ ] but they that's what a woman's
about security like I I look at my wife
now today and I look at in different
ways because when we started dating and
I moved in with her there was no
security
we all start at zero every month didn't
matter how far you work she killed it
the store last night yeah
Oh have a great week at the Ventura
comedy club doesn't matter doesn't
matter
it's Monday the 1st and we all start at
zero now what we did last month we got
to do better this one yeah it's really
weird how comedy it's really weird how
I'm making a living for yourself pushes
me luckily I was a commissioned salesman
mmm which is a comedian we really are
commissioned salesman yeah no salary in
90 days no guarantee are well you did
bad we'll give you a thousand and a 15th
and then when you're selling the second
fifteenth of the day we'll just wash
though the salary we gave you yeah
there's none of that [ __ ] yeah either
you make it or you don't
and if so we'll have some nights you
have four gigs and one of them you get
paid 50 bucks for but the other three
it's a freer than [ __ ] yeah third you
know yeah don't tell the guy who paid me
50 that I did this one for me yeah and
you can't figure out but it's such a
jerk
I mean I'm thankful every day I'm
thankful that [ __ ] I'm alive I'm
thankful I'm still doing what I like
doing you know I don't have to I'm not
forced to do it every week is I'm not
letting what you own control you and all
that [ __ ] I go out it's not a job for me
stand up it's not a job to me it's
somebody needs to do to keep money I'm
the food on the table but it's not a job
to me I don't have to make pair $8,000
mortgage
see what I'm saying yeah you got to pay
that eight grand that [ __ ] those
whiskies are a little harder and [ __ ]
on the plane his whiskey's coming down
rough yeah I keep my nut low but that's
not what we're talking about here what
we're talking about is the commitment I
didn't even know was your 10th
anniversary yeah in fact I'm just happy
that you're getting an opening to going
to Montreal whether they say yes or no
because I know to a guy like you don't
guy like me I mean you don't tell you
I'm going to Montreal yeah what you tell
yourself I'm sending a tape and
hopefully then choose me and then go to
Montreal and then I have a new set
written I'm not gonna sell patrick
swayze t-shirts at the Huq now I haven't
done that for months it's just really
weird that we live on a 90 day merit
program like when we said that to me I
mean don't count me if I'm here now you
know I'm like wow we has no idea that
he's going into a vortex and he's going
into a vortex that's psychological it
[ __ ] people up yeah because when you
bring home a report card
your father hugs you and says thank you
for the A+ son that means the world to
me I'm gonna frame that you know when
even a dog when you fetch a ball and the
dog drops the ball what do you do you
bend over and pet the dog with Tommy
nobody pat you yeah you know dog Joey's
coming with me to this gig I go to the
gig e bombs the next gig I go to I'm not
there and you get a standing ovation
under where you go where was [ __ ] why I
couldn't have been there for that yeah
you know goes like that right it's it's
just a [ __ ] nightmare and listen I'm
doing comedy 27 years and I go through
it you know me and Lee sometimes Lee
goes to the store because I didn't make
it tonight that what do you want me to
do curl up in a ball and cry no you
shake it off you know where you went
wrong I came out a little cocky I
shouldn't have said that joke upfront
but I wanted to show up fully that's
what I get for showing off and frontally
and now ii simply go around you
destroyed their own because you picked
up beer or whatever you learned the
mistake you learned the mistake this is
that's why I say failing and this is not
you're happy about it if you like it
you're like I like family and I do
listen failing means you're alive yeah
we've associated failure with debt like
it's this [ __ ] thing that would start
a scared to fail listen I'd rather you
try even though I know was a dog with
fleas
you brought it to me I knew was a dog
with fleas but who the [ __ ] am I to tell
you I think everything's a dog with
fleas you know you've been with an
investment right the almond about
investments is a dog with fleas you know
I just know what I know what I can help
you with so when you come to me with
something that's not in my field how can
I judge it you know people always ask me
why don't I judge kill Tony I love Tony
inch girl I love Brian College judge
other comics I have a hard time with
dying atomic he sucks you know why cuz
that's his dream you sucking at
carpentry that's yeah you know you
sucking it uh not taking pictures right
wherever and I'm not worried about that
but when you come to me and you go hey
man I talk to you in private you know my
dream is to photograph Led Zepplin even
though they are dead I want to
photograph the hands of that caliber you
know how can I look you in the eye who
your photography sucks I don't anything
about photography yeah how do I know
what your eye sees I do know one thing
I don't four or five people that take
pictures of me on a constant level and I
know another three or four people that
paid big money to take pictures of me
and nobody takes a better picture than
me no Felicia Michaels or the guy from
the store
Okoye yeah did you see what you sent
this the next day no I don't see it I
think he the 70cc from do you have the
check I got my headshots with Troy oh
yeah I mean - I got a headshot that was
great I just got him you're on stage
Troy is the best of what he does and
I've had people pay I pay people years
you're gonna come into a store and
they're pictures that you looking good I
mean listen I know I look like Herman
wants this but your photography I should
take that
yalbury this away and show them that one
piece of beauty that I have but the
point being who are you to tell that guy
that he's no good right
because you never know that he might be
perfect for some job out there it's it's
not that I don't know a [ __ ] with
people's dream I [ __ ] with you
be a dumb camp well that's not a drink
there's people confuse a dream with a
hobby yeah yeah a dream there's
something that you feel deep in your
boss hmm that while you're working at
the DMV
you often hate yourself and you hate
life and you're frustrated because
you're not doing what you want to do
that's a dream and you know that you
dream at first you're not gonna make no
money don't I mean my dream is to hang
pictures up of athletes and the [ __ ]
museum and that people come by every day
know why I remember this game I remember
this I got a great picture from garnet
Oh Shaq I'll [ __ ] Sid the squid the
Sports Illustrated cover he sent it to
me for Christmas he dropped it at the
store you know I would love to put a
space together just to show our
different looked every much the
different people sports aren't Huber
month Armenian month you know like just
put it I like photography I don't know
nothing about really yeah I don't know
about it but if I did like a Chinese art
month and you brought in a Buddha and a
couple pictures of China couple pictures
of Chinese people doing karate I don't
give a [ __ ] I love to do something like
that I just don't know how they even
start do you charge the painter for wall
space because you know a thousand people
that would come through there every day
I don't know how to start yeah I love
all that type of [ __ ] but that would be
a dream of mine that that's a dream of
mine when I was a kid I used to work
with flowers do you guys know that no it
was one of the ones like your mom one
part of it involvement my stepfather
when he got honey bought into a flower
thing and I gotta tell you man that's a
great business yeah I don't know what
the cost of flowers all right no it does
I can't imagine what they are now all I
know is every year as he rose sales yeah
yeah Jesus Christ these people [ __ ]
thieves you do the assortments yourself
you have fun doing that the guys in
those days I was about this is probably
between eight
ten and I'm the weekends I would go up
there to the sabes in the Sun as I was
delegated to the butcher shop that part
today so the mornings I would start with
the flower shop then in the afternoons I
don't have to go to the butcher shop so
I would get up at like 3:30 in the
morning go to Manhattan pick up the
flowers take them back to Jersey cut off
stems destem the roses that sucks well
you gotta get a rose ah and then [ __ ]
hold it then take a destem and distend
the roses and you have to do all that
[ __ ] Danny July 8 years old 10 years old
8 9 10 years old I would do that then
help his name was Ivan I would help him
but the legolas means the arrangement
and then I would put him in the front
refrigerator and people come pick him up
or they deliver him to funerals or
whatever the [ __ ] it was and when then
once I swept the floor and everything
was done at about 11:30 I would cross
the street and they had a [ __ ]
butcher shop it was really a numbers
operation and I would go back there and
I'll have to clean out the fries to
sweep the front go get the guys
cigarettes that was the easy now stop
the shelves they have like olives and
stupid [ __ ] they wouldn't make me take
out the old [ __ ] first and put the new
stuff on sold the old [ __ ] could sell
just a little tricks of the trade that
you learned you know but I'm happy I
learned all that stuff even though I
didn't become that for years I was dying
to get a stock shelving Josef hmm if
you're lonely guy and you have insomnia
go to your local supermarket those jobs
are Union when I stopped to get those
jobs when you your little brows at 6:00
in the morning yeah
and the [ __ ] of this ballots and dog
yeah [ __ ] things those guys that's a
union job I used to do that at CVS oh I
hate those guys get paid unpalatable
stock the shelves and bring them back
you know you have to but there's an
inspector who goes through the aisles he
zeroes what he needs you
come by with a [ __ ] either a pull
cart the ones you pulled at electronic
this is without you dropped the pallet
and Lee has to load them to the shelves
I was trying to get one of those jobs
for years because there were 11 to 8 hmm
their 11th date with this nobody there
yeah it is kind of weird you were saying
earlier Halleck we are who we are
like I always liked working like it's
weird that you like working nights and
then you start doing staying like you've
just kind of drawn to certain things
that like is yummy you were drawn to to
stand up from the early age like no I
was drawn to stand-up comedy on vinyl at
an early age as a fan did I think about
going to a comedy club not in a million
years when it came time to quit high
school the job I quit high school it was
a day job that after a month became a
lot load loading job but I knew one
thing I knew at the age of 10 so I was
never gonna have a day job like I just
know that like that was gonna be a
problem
and all you hear about but it's having
it to high schools this college is that
you have to work in the city and your
hours are 9:00 to 5:00 and all this [ __ ]
and I would get anxiety thinking about
it I thought would see I would be
hanging out in Ashe ways my local deli
and I would see people getting off the
bus at 6:00 and coming in for a sandwich
or a dozen eggs or yeah pound the cheese
and a pound of roast beef for the next
day's sandwich and the thrill would go
with it's always a big thrill to work in
the city when you come from my area when
you're 3 miles from the New York City it
gives you like that thing to brag what
do you do the act of standing I work at
the time I am what do you do I load
buses in doing what do you do I work in
the city pitch don't even say where you
just say the city every boy who
mr. bigshot let me uh sorry I mean you
know we're gonna ask you a question and
then it and it's gonna have a follow-up
question good so you've obviously we'd
known each other for a long time so
you've obviously always been very good
at sales yes would you say out of all
the products to push is selling yourself
was the hardest [ __ ] one follow-up
question you've had success in the last
I don't know nine years and do you think
that it was that your audience was
always out there and they just needed to
find you and now the podcast create a
source to find you or do you think that
over years you'd develop people to like
you like did you you make them like you
bite maybe salesmanship what was the
first question
so it was yourself the hardest yes
product ever sell absolutely I'm not you
were gonna gig with some money but I
used to want really greasy gigs where
the promoter wouldn't make you go to
local mall and give out flyers unlock
the people I'd rather you fire me yes
send me other ok I was never good at
that stuff yeah I was never good at
making a flyer and handing it to
somebody for somebody like for myself
yes I was always good at selling things
and when you get here you ever go to a
show that somebody runs and you get
there in the place it sold out and they
actually love that host but in reality
he's just an awful [ __ ] comic but for
some reason he this is way before social
media yeah I know Thomas that's your
emails and phone calls and text messages
will get 80 200 people to a show with a
text message and they had zero times and
they would go up them punished
audience they were getting the budget
from the house they paid they have lines
in the features and the other comments
okay but they weren't there to see those
guys they were there to see that host
and I could to figure out what it was
back then
and it was the or the sailing ship
something I had a hard time with I have
a hard time with telling people come see
me I'm a funny guy you know I'm at the
end or at 8:30 that's hard for yelling
me but then something came that it was a
misused tool for people it was called
the internet and it was fair game a guy
by the name of Dane Cook I had become a
star using a a site called myspace
mm-hmm so every comic whether they were
soldiers of Bill Hicks you know I'm a
Kellison fan do you think you think
Richard Pryor would go home at night and
get on MySpace that was my response
document do you think after Richard
Pryor would do a certain Comedy Store
he'd go down to his room at the hotel in
doing MySpace and tell people it's
[ __ ] Bela everybody got on myspace
to sell tickets but that's when I
realized what they weren't doing they
were Dane Cook was communicating with
people I started seeing salesmanship
mm-hmm now is when you talk to my
neighborhood so I started seeing people
giving away tickets or telling you they
were gonna be in town I immediately
removed myself as a comedian
and I become a consumer and I thought
how greasy is that that's sexual
harassment that's Harvey Weinstein type
site you're not I mean you're not giving
me any reason to give you consent to
touch my dick well I see a [ __ ] comic
text or post
I'm doing a show too
at this place tickets available here I
want to reach through the internet and
smack them because they're telling me
something instead of giving me something
and after you give them something then
you sell or something mm-hmm
what was the last time you went up to a
girl told you you loved her and put your
hands on a veg never they'll throw you
in jail especially the LA what if that
girl does have a crush on you or you
kiss her neck for 10 minutes and tell
her how you gonna take it to a date the
Denny's and how you guys gonna be grand
slam your big Grand Slam is [ __ ] cuz I
know the waiter at Denny's he's kissing
you on the neck then he puts his hand
between your legs it's a way different
game so I draw I wrote a [ __ ] podcast
on MySpace that was published area
blotter
a blog that was horrific
I would just take this segment of my
life and the order it happened things
that changed my life and I wrote a blog
and they worked for about 18 months
because I was endearing myself to people
before I could sell you something I have
to endear myself to you I have to give
you a reason why why did they get so
hard to sell and shirts because you
don't see nothing
yeah yes you dick yeah you signed four
papers I shake your hand and I leave I
saw your car you drive it every month
yeah I saw you an iPhone you drunk here
you usually so you yeah about water
[ __ ] Dodger game you gonna drink it
right this is yeah I saw yes insurance
you walk out of there and the set in
question yeah was by the time Twitter
and Facebook came together I if you want
me to lie to you I could lie to you and
tell you that when you're a telemarketer
when I read the ads on this show I
believed in these products I really
liked Squarespace mm-hmm I know twenty
people built a website it was
yeah I think Felicia built my original
own with Squarespace so and it's
motivational for people get your
business going and stuff like that well
I get contacted to do Squarespace I
enjoy referring Squarespace hmm
I don't know what the point was here
what was the point the reef is getting
Tardelli the companies who advertise
with you you believe in I believe it but
my job at the end of the day is to lead
them to a website the people listen to
you I need you to go to Squarespace if
you're thinking about a website because
I'm gonna cut your deal okay I'm not
telling you this is an ad read I'm
telling you the truth my job is to get
you to a website my job is in comedy is
to get you to the club to see me yeah
okay
so in all this myspace Facebook we're
switching over we don't want to be copy
this in my space we're going on with the
theme Danny Zuckerberg and then you
might as well be on Twitter I still
remember a certain episode of Romans
that I went up there and I said I want
to be friends with nobody on Twitter oh
you know how many times I could eat
those words now that I have personal
relationships with people on Twitter
from Jenica James Jones to [ __ ] you
know these are my friends I consider
them friends and fans a family I don't
know [ __ ] fans so I ain't my words I
was big enough a man declare there's
people on Facebook buried wasn't Bablu
and your best friends of the podcast you
know they're your friends now from the
infinite so yeah I figured out a way how
to sell myself for people to come to the
shows but I have to show them something
I give them a taste of my music what's
in my head
I want to know what's in the Agostino
head I love it when people start podcast
and they want to do everything but give
people the information they want which
is to know about you when I see you I
was somebody calls me up with a podcast
about 20 moving parts
yeah I avoid it like the plague those
like gimmicky podcast yeah
hourly MS yeah yada yada well you get a
podcast when you give me a gimmicky
podcast is truly truly moving pieces
mm-hmm a podcast is to three people
having a conversation about a topic and
you tapping into my conversation that's
it playing the [ __ ] simple my goal
with the podcast was to complete a
circle we talk this is free I don't want
a dime from me I don't want a pantry and
I'm not gonna shoot videos for you that
ship sail I'm too [ __ ] old
I give me the past two cans for free I
get on Twitter I talk about it on
Facebook you know we do the periscope
and then when I get to your town you
come to the show there's a catalyst to
all this and it's a podcast the podcasts
and many other things when I did the
longest yard after I shot the longest
shot was very frustrated why because
actually I had the same problem
everybody what everybody else didn't am
one of the deal I put I thought that
listen you never know what you're gonna
do in this town to watch you the Tiffany
Haddish it was that movie took her from
eating garbage to [ __ ] living in
Beverly Hills and I applaud her no
matter what happens what goes down
that's in but having that talents of big
launch just being here you create
opportunities for yourself and sometimes
an opportunity opens up and boom you're
there what if tomorrow he's doing a spot
at some [ __ ] hellhole and somebody
from NBC sees them says I want to leave
to do a daytime 15-minute thing on the
internet every day and I'm gonna give
you ten the ramp recently called
D'Agostino and god I know what they're
talking about
oh but you're gonna help me write that
[ __ ] now give you 3,000 now we can there
you go
then people gonna go whoa but the
Agostino not a writer why he gonna
attend then the Agostino gonna get a new
car but after two years every club
D'Agostino walks into
he wouldn't be anything without Lisa at
yep and and you're like wait a second
it's exactly how it goes there was an
opportunity there I seized it and now
that's the way it is and you know how
you [ __ ] hate on me yeah
oh he's not he wouldn't be anything
without lee-sia really go ask Lisa at
least I have to tell you if that's the
truth right well you say I'll say yeah I
write 60% of them but [ __ ] the
Agostino come up with some whoppers
while we shoot yeah you know I'm saying
so you know you take me to a club with
you to open but guess what if I bomb
that club's gonna tell Joey next time
maybe bring somebody else yeah you got
to keep did work knowing maybe someone
gave it to you I also let you walk home
after your flight reservation I call the
airlines and DJ MOJ time you got a
boggle area that's why you can't be mad
at Dane Cook though either because he
did that but he he was he he he could
have been not funny right like he
touched everybody and connected by
everybody met by myspace but what if he
wasn't funny like Saint put him work
yeah he put a got a great story about
that this is a very true story
you know late 90s early 2000 one of the
hottest clubs in the country was Houston
and I spoke to a friend of mine in
Houston who goes oh my god I can't wait
Dane Cook this coming this weekend I
always like then he was very popular in
LA he was starting to this is before
that bar on Sunset on Tuesdays he was
already getting popular at the Laugh
Factory people want to see Dane at the
Laugh Factory and one Monday I had
Latino night there because I was walking
then he was walking out he'd be like a
guest on Latino night like I he doing he
was good I go how is Houston
I'll never forget this I know how is
Houston goes Houston was a great [ __ ]
show was a great week but it was just a
bit too long Joey
he thought it was Wednesday through
Sunday and he looked at me goes I got a
figure out of the way they shortened
that that's why when he started hitting
theater
and arenas it didn't surprise me he was
over it from the beginning and his
mental state he was done with that he
had already done colleges he had been
sprinkling seeds all around the country
from colleges for two or three years he
was just doing colleges building up
these little markets that nobody else
thought about going to just dropping the
seeds and what do you think happens what
the [ __ ] do you think happens that's
what happens you know people who
remember Kevin Hart Kevin Hart went to
Montreal or whatever I don't know the
story I'm not here but I do know that he
gets ABC sit down and it was supposed to
be the hottest thing everybody got a
couple seasons and I think one away I do
know that he called his agent the next
and he goes take my calendar book every
week
pay me $1,500 and I want you to give the
tickets away hmm
because I'm still a TV guy they're still
gonna come cuz I'm the TV guy just give
ticket away well whoever pays pays if
not cop I'm all out I want those rooms
packed and he made all those free
tickets he made them pay the next time
and he came back again the next year he
did the same thing every year big
built-in wouldn'ta theaters and filets
and stadiums yeah that takes an enormous
commitment it's not a one-year thing
it's a three-year thing you're looking
at you're looking at a three-year cycle
I'm gonna go 45 weeks for three years
but each 18 months I'm gonna move up a
cycle go from clubs to theaters this
poor bastard I kidnapped I'm going to
Tucson he's been calling me everything
got a mother painting on my progress
last time I want the Tempe told me team
is showing up now he gets who that's I
Palma now before I get that
so I know torch them a little yeah
saying I can't get him good so if you
don't know that when you're going into
it like I wish I have a comedy at the
plan at the three-year but you can't you
can't have a plan you only plan this to
get on stage that's your only plan well
Joey I want to be a good lawyer well
then you have to hang on a lot of
[ __ ] courtrooms my friend why the
court rooms every night yeah but I need
to study will you study after the court
room
yeah but I also need a job you yourself
in a [ __ ] delivery or you can you
book whatever the [ __ ] that is new
beginner yeah yeah if you really want it
it happens but I don't want you to think
it happens just because it's supposed to
happen well it's also crazy how it's
different for everybody like do you see
that thing that Sebastian put up with
him and it was like the news guy NBC
Nightly News did it interview with him
at the store no it was in I heard this
story before but he was a waiter at the
Four Seasons and and they didn't say
this on that but I've heard that he
didn't go on the road as much as
everybody else like he stayed and worked
and and just worked only at the store
really or around La it's pretty lucky he
would go and do his spots on his break I
was like gee that's and that's anxiety
at all with his way to sooner take the
restaurant put a leather jacket on and
go up there get off the store get in
this car and go back to the four seasons
wow you know I have problems with
raising comic in LA but I don't have
problems with raising a comic away if he
knows where his position is he always
knew where he stood he went on that tour
then he wasn't that cool with tap and
all those guys in the Wild West world
would Steve Byrne Oh was he on Vince
Vaughn's Wild West things and he that's
right he was on that man and he's got a
fantastic career yeah
but I never want anybody to think that
he just happens over there and then the
I remember Tim ten years ago he was the
favorite comic in the club in Addison
Texas and they're going Joe have you
seen him lately
at the store and they know it's
brilliant it's like a new Dice Clay
clean yeah so people [ __ ] love it he
jumps up like Dane Cook who she's not to
mention his work ethic yeah he's working
it comes from the old school
you know Italian he's got good work I
mean you can't imagine that like he said
he would show up on his vest change go
onstage and go back to the restaurant
like you can't imagine I work out I
think like that not don't I thank you
hiya policeman all these guys Bilborough
all these guys are doing well here all
have one thing in common and that's time
that includes Joe Rogan it's time Ari
Shaffir 20 years time this is time this
is time this is a commitment but again I
don't want it to harp on just stand-up
comedy this is no matter what you do you
want to be a good cop
you got to be a rookie you got a [ __ ]
put out flares you gotta change flats
you gotta save cats and then you gotta
learn the other angle of it you got a
burn community service and they take by
the time you learn it all you already
been in it and yet you can't prepare for
this career that's not really a career
you can prepare for even if you go to
college and they tell you all the
statistics and you learn all the graphs
and [ __ ] you're not doing it to you
there but whatever you planning on doing
you have to put time into it D'Agostino
what was there between your old marriage
in this marriage yeah I mean that's a
great point it's just the lines of
difference the time the [ __ ] time
that you put in what did you where'd you
learn this room my mistake of the first
marriage thank you yeah you Dumbo yes
sir I believe mistakes did you make with
the one-eyed Mexican
are you gonna repeat him try not to know
you know what I got the vote for
somebody asked me about this I know how
to destroy a house you don't say you
want me to destroy your house I'm moving
with you and Jen by the end of the month
gentle be out of that yeah
we go and blow man with vicodins in your
pocket yeah yeah Troy your house you
know I know how to destroy a marriage I
did it I know how to destroy a marriage
welcome my house my house is the den
apiece nobody raises their voice and
mouth she yells at me and she smiles
while she's yelling at me you stupid
[ __ ] you know that there's a but I have
to work at that yeah you know when I was
a kid and I was a Spanish kid man
there was nothing more than I wanted
damn that white ass back to we ate
dinner together don't be curse at the
table and I didn't have that but I would
watch the Waltons and all those TV shows
I go I like the Louisa houses and mom
was gonna buy me all when I only could
sit together and they'd say a little Jew
prayer before that it you know pass
around a penny and look how shiny it was
whatever the [ __ ] Jews do before it
dinner but if I shine on that penny how
do you know
[ __ ] though I'm stupid jokes act but
I yearn for that and now I love when
people approach me for different stuff
how I look at projects and stuff like
that you can't take time away from me
because I know what it means to them I
know what it means to have a safe house
I can go out for weeks in the world
my wife wouldn't say a word for me
especially when she got the checks in my
hand it's not about that it's saving our
marriage it's about spending time
together
it's little things you don't see from
the first marriage mm-hmm that's why
your second marriage will last forever
unless you pull it up some [ __ ]
chicks ass and you know and your wife
finds out that she's Russian they know
everything find that you travel with a
bug you got GPS on your right yeah as a
matter of fact she's listening right the
live stream the Agostini you got a lot
of things going on what are you credited
for the last four years huh what am i
credited for what do you occur what are
you crediting it for like what what did
like you write every day yeah
you write every day hmm how long if I
could squeeze in a half hour I'm happy
in the day time warning in the evenings
jokes or ideas idea it bits you write it
goals
yeah daily weekly weekly for the podcast
a lot I write I write each podcast I try
to write down what I want to talk about
so I'll just invite you over to [ __ ]
waste your time you know I'm always I
have a really bad anxiety that I'm gonna
fight someone to do my podcast and I sit
there and I don't have anything
important to say to them do you
Wikipedia people depend on who they are
I mean some of them I got no like really
really well but then some of them I like
I go google them first you know and if I
can find say five to Wikipedia I don't
want you know the show saying yeah weird
thing about yeah like I like the
Wikipedia and be prepared yeah ten
questions like the Actors Studio that's
not me I just want the flow to go
wherever the [ __ ] it flows
I mean sometimes sometimes I learn stuff
I didn't know about people which is kind
of cool and you can bring it up and then
it's a question that then no one ever
either or no one ever asked me that on
my on a podcast before it's on I like
that though I like this whole Punk I
never did the podcast to get success I
just wanted to have my work my what I
was thinking out there I think that's
very important
but if your comic or an actor or you
know you want to make a difference or
something like that I don't care if you
do a podcast for 30 years and don't get
any more than 50 downloads a month you
stuck with it and you proved your point
and you got 50 people who listened to
you yeah that's big to get 50 people
listened to you never mind you the two
thousand ten million like Rogan that's a
feat that's you know and even the other
guys and Conan has a podcast so even
starting a podcast is intimidating
mm-hmm but it you and you're only
intimidated if you're doing it for the
wrong reasons if you're doing it for the
right reasons
I love doing my podcast because I know
I'm reaching one person somebody will o
be a problem
somebody who got wrapped up and came out
on Sunday doesn't know what to do and
they're confused I want them to know
that there's no rules if you want it you
could take it you could go get it if you
really want it if you want to dig around
and give yourself excuses and trip all
over yourself then you're never gonna
get it you just procrastinate and trust
me I was a procrastinate it took me two
years to get on stage you know or year
and a half something ridiculous
ridiculous to get on stage the first
time Wow but I like what you and we both
do on this podcast is basically for
bogey is I'm very proud of you that you
stuck with something for really now this
year you goes to stick with two things
whether it's whacking off every day
killing the fly off your neck every day
I whack off everything he has flies on
his neck yes a little ice water in his
house
so how this leaks out of his neck my
emotional support fly fly breeze I'm on
the plane when I look cage Lee that's
the new t-shirt emotional support fly
little [ __ ] fly on it please little
decoy the Flies got a little vest don't
give no ideas as best a little doing
there's a clearance sale December
he's on roller skates with a Monday I'm
very proud of you thinking you know what
does your podcast come on so I do two a
week and it's usually Monday and
Thursday but you know I'm still getting
for that yeah I mean it sometimes I
gotta be flexible because it's hard to
get [ __ ] guests I have a co-host - I
mean you know how it is to get guests
but when you have a podcast it's not
huge it's really [ __ ] hard to get
guests and then you get pissed at people
like you said no to me didn't have time
but you did that guy's you know that
means little things like that but with
you know it shows jobs as long as I get
to out I'm happy but it's pretty much
like Monday in tears they go out on your
plate yeah wife the job stands up you
live in the same building as your parent
yes they're across the hall they come in
at the end time when underwear on yeah I
don't know what's going on my foot dad
Mike I know what's going on my toe take
a look at it well yeah
we gotta cut the nail it look like a
[ __ ] zu looks like before I came over
here I was taking the Christmas lights
off my mom's roof were you yeah good
good good but you know I'm very lucky
that my family runs a building in Los
Angeles because it's [ __ ] expensive
here I'm lucky that I'm from Los Angeles
a lot of comics had to move out here
that's that I I applaud anybody had to
do that I don't know if I would have
been able to do that but I already lived
out here and I'm lucky that my family
had a building that they run and I get
to I get pretty cheap rent I mean I'm
not getting it for free but I pay a
little discount if I can help Sal well
you're a young couple yeah and you're
both trying to make moves and yeah I'm
just wanting to put you on the podcast
Thank You San Jose with me [ __ ] yeah
February 14th through the 17th nice
we'll be going original Joe's in the
States
[ __ ] me I never been good I've never
done San Jose
wait till you [ __ ] see this the high
ceilings I can't wait for it to some
Rijal Joe don't even look at him he had
he lost credit bill went towards all
Joe's the San Francisco with Paul huh
they signed up for some look at San
Francisco for the eyes trip they didn't
I go to Virgil jobs yes I know yes I did
they tweeted at me what did you go with
little Paula
it was right before we broke up you know
what I was thinking about the other day
when you do the San Francisco punchline
the hotel they put you watch your feet
all that cheese you know is truth is the
[ __ ] I don't think I've had like an
another one is good since then
especially in this [ __ ] neighborhood
with these [ __ ] I went to bagley Al
Jarreau
what can I try it I Pagliacci cioppino
they cook it in like white water you
don't I mean like they're not cooking in
a white wine but you can tell like
there's no flavor you got a you got a
cook cioppino and white wine what did
you like from Pagliacci then there's
good pasta dishes you're gonna go to the
pot I have one pasta dish that sensation
which one you get the one with with the
lambs meat and the meat okay we'll go
have to try that next time I got like a
chicken all of those okay that beau
levesque
best ever bad really I think I'm a nice
bonus and they give it to you the
home-cooked fresh noodles they make the
rules their fellow Cheney okay and you
could taste like that was watching The
Sopranos dared that you take the pasta
you drain it then you put butter on it
and you put a cup of sauce in it you
stir it for the first minute
so the pastas fresh and absorbs little
sauce a lot of people to understand that
concept yeah when you first get it you
have to drain it put it down put a piece
of butter in there and pour a little bit
of sauce and stir it for two minutes so
that sauce goes into this yeah yeah you
don't just nothing apart yeah no no no
no no besides San Jose you gotta need
dates brother I had a pretty [ __ ]
busy January but I have nothing really
in February besides San Jose all right
so you would me in San Jose the 14th
through the 17th yeah then the following
week I'm at Treasure Island and San
Francisco on the tornad Las Vegas in the
22nd and the Fox Theater and
[ __ ] Tucson Arizona and the
23rd that's a tour with Kate Quigley
nice I know the tickets are a little
extra in Vegas from bringing artillery
or [ __ ] Dallas and beside that
D'Agostino I just wanted to tell you and
Liam both of proud of the botys thank
you and that means a lot
proud that least stuck with something
for a year I hope he continues to stick
with it or that I'll [ __ ] take
important area for a weekend disappears
you saying that is one of those things
that I was talking about that just goes
like okay the consistency does work you
know it's just hearing listen
consistency doesn't work it's boring
it's boring yeah you know every well
specially you don't see the payoff right
away entirely every 90 days is
psychiatrist bill you hate your wife
yeah and everybody because you don't see
the results yeah the results are
happening yeah you're just not giving
you enough time to let the miracle
happen and once the miracle happens now
you want to get stronger that now it
dies yeah one coke yeah there's a point
where like you know I just count me on
my life and then at the at the [ __ ]
twelve year mark how many crazies let me
say what happened yes
I was about to take a shower
it was fourth there 45 and I had a
birthday party at the house my daughter
is 16 other princesses all day there was
a little gay boy with a whistle and
Donna Summer Music and we would have had
it off but it was still a great time but
I have for 30 min my daughter watches
something little mursalin get ready and
mercy while you go get ready
my wife had a brush your hair and put a
[ __ ] princess costume on so as I'm
going to shower I'm thinking to myself
and something just came to my mind Chris
the palette christabella is what's the
guy from my Kamali
Billy Gardell Billy got those managers
Christopher okay since day one
he's never fired christabella Chris the
pellet holes do the punchline that land
the [ __ ] used to hold it I don't know
what the politics are there okay I was
thinking about calling christabella
cuz when I got here in 98 he was very
good to me they were doing a pilot and
he wasn't even my manager he made a call
for me so I was just thinking about
Chris dependent and I started thinking
about the other hand a punch spot like
why don't I go there because it was an
hour drive from the airport and we left
on a Monday morning Rogen we didn't
think of it - I was almost delayed and
I'm making a mental note I'm never
coming back out here or whatever but I
remembered that specific weekend and how
we did five or six shows and I bought
four of those shows but that's the tape
that if you ever see on YouTube of me
calling Duncan and harassing them for
being involved with devil worshippers
that week it's on YouTube it's got a
couple million hits that red band makes
me this is when red band was just Joe's
cameraman okay and it was me Ari Joe
Tate and red ban on the road every
weekend and there was a lot of
uncomfortable times you know Rogen will
rent the car and he didn't know he was
going so I would get into arguments you
know the day that
they were telling me that Duncan was a
devil worshiper and I left him a message
they're gonna [ __ ] him in the ass and
all that that was the weekend and I had
to weigh 400 pounds and I was on skates
tongue everybody and [ __ ] and some way
in the back had called me and she knows
who would [ __ ] you like it was just a
god-awful weekend and this is 19 this is
2002 2003 I was already a regular at the
store for four or five years I'd been on
MADtv I'll never forget some lady yelled
who would [ __ ] you and I'm annoying not
even like people laughed this [ __ ] like
it was just a rough weekend but cuz I
was drying myself off when I came out of
the shower like that's as good as it
gets like that was as good as it gets
and I got dressed and the first guy
called his red bat like a red man you
got a minute he was in North Carolina
don't you kill Tommy I know I'm in that
weekend we went to Atlanta and we taped
a thing for Duncan and I bombed
we all laughed about me Bob and like
having a rough time huh I had a follow
Ari and I just had horrible material all
I cared about was smart and coke and I
go red man tell me to my face that
that's not wasn't as good as it - house
it really was and I started getting
emotional and I waited ten minutes like
called the rhogam he picked up later you
got two minutes I know I mean that time
I went through Atlanta and I wand and
the lady heckled me and said who would
[ __ ] you and he started laughing because
I wrote a joke about it yeah he wrote a
joke about it yeah and he goes I know
that was as good as it got for me bro
bombing being a feature act in a hotel
like yeah I mean it's business gets like
you were having the time of your life
titled my wife that weekend like we
would all eat together
like five of us would eat together
nobody would eat without anybody you
know I think we were smoking all dope at
this time so we were smoking dope
together those tours
a reflection of what I'm doing on stage
today you're gonna go both tears have to
go on $20,000 you know we're just the
bottom man like I was the bottom man it
was Ari and me and everybody hated me
and Ari
they love Joe but they ain't us but
those are the as good as it gets you
don't know it why you're going through
it but the education I got from those
gigs are Who I am tonight so I'm really
proud that you never gave up
I'm really proud that you flip the
switch and even though you're married
you've worked out a a yin and yang
situation to continue a family and grow
I hope that you do get your tape out
there that you go to Montreal yeah I
wish you both a lot of success Lee thank
you you are a great comedic writer you
are we got woody Thank You Allan I don't
I hope you don't not a pedophile [ __ ]
you cousin but you are the next 40 al
you did the green at the store the other
night that everybody was saying it and
for you a way way way ahead of me my
first year the only thing I had on you
was I we won a national contest but you
gotta remember it's not how many people
you shoot it to you shoot hmm so don't
worry about that stuff that's the only
thing I had on you you comedy-wise and
talent-wise you have me by [ __ ] more
than those well I appreciate it I'm
sorry I know I don't know it there's
part of me that like it's even weird
like sometimes when I'm like only doing
ten part of me is like kinda wish I was
doing 15 like it it's like it's I just
want to do more stand-up and I
definitely if I got an offer to be on
the road every week I'm not saying I
wouldn't take it but it's right now I
just want to be able to do more it's
just that it is tough for me like what
you said is not as tough when you do
badly then if I only have one set and I
don't do well I'll be sad until the next
day
a big-time gay comic the quality of
interview available dan I'll do it all
day I'll dance for him let me do 20
minutes I've done those row gigs bro
they're just [ __ ] it makes you a
beast I'm excited I'm excited to do
those do those dumb shows on the road or
like a bartender did the last time I did
bonkers they put me in this giant
[ __ ] room there was no one in there
and they told me to go onstage anyway I
reward and get paid I had to go up there
like an idiot and do stand-up for the
empty chairs literally not one person in
there and then when you show up at the
bar show in downtown LA and all those
other guys are eating a dick you're
gonna go up and kill because you know
how to [ __ ] do horrible rooms like
that happen a Riverside it was a
restaurant where no one was paying
attention and because of the show I did
at Eddie Bravo's thing where no one was
paying attention I knew I had to
approach it a little differently and
after the show of the Booker you
actually just booked me again because
three different people like I love that
guy like just being a they had no idea
who I was
but it's it's cool to like fit when you
see something again that you bombed out
once you like oh I can at least I have
an idea of how to handle it differently
this and this goes across the board for
whatever you're doing when I was roofing
these principles apply I was a plumber
these principles apply no matter what
career you have that you're looking for
advancement it's all the same path it's
time
and then opportunities one day you're
gonna be there seven years you're gonna
go what am I gonna get a raise all I
want to raise for a dollar and they call
you in the office if the guy that was
your boss is quitting and you get a
three dollar raise and you don't Jesus
Christ God works in mysterious ways no
you punched the [ __ ] clock you don't
eventually get money not today you might
not get it today it might be in the
future and the work you guys are putting
in right now in the building blocks yeah
so when you do get to that level you
don't fall apart on me hmm I don't even
know what the [ __ ] going on look at me
I did the work and I fall apart at the
seams I did the work I wrote on the gram
but as I got crabs anyway I want to
thank you the AG esteem I think you have
the show brother
Oh San Jose will see us and I don't want
to thank the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
for always being here and being a savage
infant continuing his comedy quest but
before we leave I want to talk to you
about a few things all right things you
could do with Squarespace all right I
mean they're never in you could turn
your cool idea into a new website you
could showcase your work you could put
blog or publish content you could sell
products and services of all kinds you
could promote your physical and online
businesses and announce an upcoming
event or special project listen
Squarespace does this by giving you
beautiful templates created by
world-class designers with a powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online plus the ability to
customize the look and feel settings
product and more with just a few clicks
everything is optimized for your mobile
site right out of the box it's a new way
to buy domains and choose from over 200
extensions free and secure hosting
nothing to watch or upgrade and 24/7
award-winning customer service we're
gonna get that from Squarespace all
right so if you're ready to start a new
business you want to make it stand out
you know sketch started with square pace
Squarespace
Squarespace I'm sorry so do me a favor
right now to the church family okay
you're looking for something to do
you're looking for some it's a new part
of the year you got gold ain't nobody
gonna know whether you're making music
nobody's gonna know about it and that's
just gonna no the Bluebird of happiness
I'm not gonna knock on your door and
spread the word that you're mixing
[ __ ] beats so you got to start
somewhere I'm gonna give you the
opportunity your Uncle Joe is gonna send
you go check out squarespace.com it's a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code Church CH you
are CH to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain it's
that easy
that's squarespace.com and to church
okay like I said beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and you
could turn your idea which is marvelous
into a new website and showcase to the
world the beautiful work that you do
again go to Squarespace calm for a free
trial and use offer code church to save
10% off the purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com enter code
Church CH you are CH and again you're
still working on your resolutions you
know I know you're trying I love you
helped was one of them
get yourself a kettlebell go get some
shroom tech support go get some shrimp
Tech immune go get some supplements from
Hahn it honor is the leader in
supplements whether it's it you hear me
talk about the shrimp export why because
the mushrooms give you more oxygen to
your lungs when you're working out
listen I don't know why I'm just Tonya I
dropped one of those before I go to
jiu-jitsu and I'm flipping [ __ ]
like Jojo Marathi and I'm saying
number two you fly a lot there's germs
everywhere you gotta go with shrimp tank
immune why so you don't walk around with
a little Japanese guy with a mask on
your face at the airport who needs that
aggravation be a [ __ ] man eat their
germs you know I'm saying so what I'm
saying to you is honor is the way to go
I love on it you say Joey what do you
like about it
I love the alpha brain I love the
Mexican chocolate protein there's so
many things that island has to offer you
but you have to go there so do me a
favor either respect for me the Joey in
the new year your uncle Joey and
yourself you work your resolution to get
healthy go to audit calm right now take
a look at the great selection they start
without forebrain if you don't like him
to give you your money back gaurantee
didn't want to see the product go to
eyelid not calm right now impress in
church I check up and get 10% off from
you order and it gets delivered right to
your door okay I want to thank the
Agostino order and the name of your
podcast homeschool podcast I want to
thank the Flying Jew and congratulate
him on its progress and I want to thank
you guys for listening and starting the
year off with your uncle Joey
you bad [ __ ] stay black
have a great day and don't let nobody
[ __ ] with you remember brayer next
weekend
the 22nd to the 24th I'll see you
savages down there kick this
[ __ ] mealy